[Music]
so
[Music]
what's up guys
we've got two of the coolest desks of
2021 in singapore in my home we've got
the omni desk ichi collection the kawa
table top beautiful uh teak wood on this
with epoxy resin then i also have the
secret lab magnus desk
one is designed one is functionality
which one is right for you
let's talk about
what's up guys before we get into this
i'm going to tell you about each of the
tables clip notes version if you haven't
watched our reviews on the tables
respectively you can click there but
don't do it wait i'll just give you the
30 second spill on it okay this table
top is a teak wood it's part of this all
new ichi collection by omnidesk every
piece of wood is unique no two will ever
be the same you got this epoxy resin in
this it's blue but you can get it
without the resin if you want to do that
it's beautiful it's i mean this is
craftsmanship at its highest level it's
an awesome looking desk but it's not
just about
functionality it's also about aesthetics
let's talk about where this is going to
fit into your home this is going to be a
piece of furniture this is going to be
for someone maybe you're an accountant a
lawyer maybe you're a a
professor or maybe you just want a
beautiful tabletop in your home you're
like look i wanted something i could put
my lamps on my cameras that i have here
maybe some vases and maybe just some
pictures of my family but at the same
time i want to throw my laptop on here i
want to do a little bit of work or i
want to meet some clients and i want
something that's going to stand out in
my studio or study this might be the
table that you will choose
this is very heavy
price point is very very different
versus the secret lab magnus this is an
investment piece it can range anywhere
from a thousand plus to two thousand odd
singapore dollars or even higher
depending on the wood that you get and
the size but this is something that's
going to stay in your home for a very
long period of time so that in a
nutshell is the omnidesk uh kawa
collection now let's check out the
secret lab magnus and see if that is the
right desk for you check it out
all right guys we're now in my studio
with the secret lab magnus desk as you
can tell this is a very very different
setup i mean you can put a lot of those
things on the omni desk but i use this
for a lot of my work because of course i
got this 34 34-inch asus pro art monitor
with the uh mount on it i've got my
macbook pro here i got my macbook
speakers so this is really where i do a
lot of my work and also because i have a
lot of things plugged in i need better
cable management now that's not to say
that you can't do cable management with
the omni desk you can but
this is designed with cable management
right back here so you really don't see
any cables unless i pull them out then
of course i have magnets so i can hold
them in place if i want to do that this
is also a magnetic top as well so if i
have any magnets i want to pop around
here like this put up a charging cable
for a phone or anything else like that i
can do that and no issues at all but
this is a really good overall desk now
the only downside is this is not height
adjustable unlike the omni desk that
gives you a lot of versatility this is
pretty much a standard size of course
you can raise the desk up to 20
millimeters on each of the four legs or
you can adjust it a little bit if you
have some off uh if your flooring isn't
as even as you would like it to be sort
of balance everything out but this is a
very
work-centric gamer-centric desk i mean
yes you can use this as a professional
as well but as you can tell by the
design the rgb lights
the way that it is the sort of the
aesthetics of it it is meant for a
different customer out there
um but overall this is a very different
price point as well it comes around 499
singapore dollars thereabouts so free
american folks out there buying this in
the us i think it's around 300
thereabouts
we'll put we'll put it right here at the
bottom of the screen with the actual us
pricing is i'm just guessing off the top
of my head but yeah you're looking at a
few thousand dollars
versus
500 singapore dollars so there is going
to be a difference but the cable
management on this desk is my favorite
feature of it
as you can tell it's very streamlined
and i don't like clutter on my desk you
know i like things to be organized if
you're that kind of person you're really
going to like the magnus desk so this is
not really a versus video it's just more
about highlighting two of the best desks
in my personal opinion of 2021 in
singapore and letting you know the pros
and the cons of each to see which desk
is right for you so anyway if this video
was helpful let us know in the comments
section below like always follow us on
facebook subscribe to us on youtube like
this video it helps out the channel
quite a bit stay safe and i'll chat to
you very soon take care
[Music]